[Música]
cerca nuestro algún animal está
defecando de hecho el reino animal
produce a diario una cantidad de
estiércol equiparable al caudal de agua
que cae de las cataratas Victoria cómo
es posible entonces que el planeta no
esté cubierto de excremento se lo
debemos agradecer al humilde escarabajo
pelotero por alimentarse del excedente
capaz de enterrar en una noche 250 veces
el peso de su propio cuerpo estos
notables insectos trabajan muy deprisa
con la interminable cantidad de
eses más de 7,000 especies conocidas de
escarabajos estercoleros hacen una labor
de limpieza profunda en cinco
continentes excepto en la Antártida la
primera tarea de estos escarabajos es
Localizar el estiércol algunos viven en
la zona anal de animales más grandes
listos para salir cuando esos animales
defecan otros detectan con el olfato las
eces que que los animales dejan en el
camino el excremento de un elefante
puede atraer en 15 minutos 4000
escarabajos estercoleros por eso en
cuanto uno de ellos encuentra el
excremento debe trabajar muy deprisa
para apropiarse del botín la mayoría de
las especies se dividen en tres grupos
principales peloteros cavadores y
moradores los peloteros forman una
pelota de estiércol y con las patas
traseras la transportan rodando a un
sitio alejado de los competidores
parejas potenciales se balanzano la
pelota y en cuanto el dueño de la pelota
elige su pareja ambos entierran esa
pelota en el suelo cuando la pelota está
bajo tierra la hembra pone un huevo allí
dentro los cavadores proceden de otra
manera cuando excavan debajo de una
deposición algunos arrastran excremento
dentro del suelo lo compactan y moldean
distintas masas llamadas masas nido
pelotas de estiércol o salchichas de
estiércol según sea su forma y tamaño
los cavadores machos hacen un
espectacular despliegue de cuernos para
disputar con otros Machos El dominio de
los túneles que defienden hasta que la
hembra haya puesto su huevo algunos
cavadores Machos evitan la lucha
haciéndose pasar por hembras Sin Cuernos
y de este modo entran sigilosamente a
los túneles para aparearse mientras Los
guardianes están
distraídos el tercer grupo está formado
por los moradores que tienen un método
más directo al desovar dentro del mismo
excremento de este modo las crías quedan
más expuestas a la depredación A
diferencia de las crías de peloteros Y
cavadores a medida que las larvas se
alimentan cavan numerosos túneles en el
estiércol y dejan restos que son
rápidamente colonizados por bacterias y
hongos y que luego desaparecen con la
erosión una vez que las larvas nacen ya
sea dentro de un túnel una pelota o un
excremento consumen el estiercol hasta
llegar a pupa por el proceso de
metamorfosis y luego escarabajo adulto
además de limpiar el estiércol el
trabajo de estos insectos tiene una gran
importancia
ecológica en primer lugar son agentes
secundarios para dispersarse semillas el
excremento de los monos jabalíes y otros
animales está repleto de las semillas
que comen a través de las frutas cuando
los escarabajos entierran sus pelotas de
excremento involuntariamente protegen
esas semillas de los predadores
propiciando sus posibilidades de
germinación Para aprovechar semejante
ventaja a una planta sudafricana ha
evolucionado para producir semillas cuyo
aspecto y olor son muy parecidos al
estiércol de un animal confundiendo así
a la escarabajo que engañado las
entierra los escarabajos estercoleros
también cumplen un importante papel en
los sistema agrícolas el ganado bovino y
ovino por ejemplo produce una gran
cantidad de excremento que contiene
nutrientes beneficiosos para las plantas
los escarabajos desarman el excremento y
lo entierran en túneles profundos dentro
del suelo facilitando a las raíces de
las plantas el acceso a esos nutrientes
el trabajo de estos insectos En
beneficio de los agricultores se ha
estimado en un valor anual de 380
millones de dólares americanos en
Estados Unidos y de 367 millones de
libras británicas en el Reino Unido
estos escarabajos también pueden ayudar
a combatir el calentamiento global pues
reducen la emisión de gases de efecto
invernadero asociada a la agricultura
los microbios que se desarrollan en
estiercol con bajo contenido de oxígeno
producen metano un potente gas de efecto
invernadero pero los escarabajos
oxigenan el estiércol cuando excavan
túneles en su interior impidiendo que
los microbios produzcan metano el
escarabajo estercolero esparce las
semillas colabora con los agricultores y
combate el cambio climático y todo con
solo hacer su tarea la próxima vez que
te topes con estiercol en el bosque o en
el quizás sientas la tentación de
observarlo más de
cerca te interesan los insectos permite
que te presentemos a la realeza la reina
hormiga de fuego aprende cómo gobierna
su reino en este video y suscríbete a
nuestro canal para ver más Ted Ed en
español